(upbeat beatbox music)
- Ooh.
- I feel like something's gonna jump out.
- Opening the box.
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)
- What is your real name?
- When people ask about the
real name, it's almost like
we're characters or we're in
a stage play or something.
- No, but your real name.
I just told you.
- Does every trans
person transition fully?
- Every trans person's full
transition is different.
- You don't need to look
like me, you don't need
to look like you.
- What are some issues that
have come up while dating?
Oh Lord, sweet baby Jesus.
We could be here all day.
- 'cause I don't date the
conventional type of person,
it makes it a little bit more challenging.
- I've always dated cis men,
but recently I've dated a
trans guy and the sex
is really, really good.
So I'm excited about (laughs).
- Am I still straight
if I want to fuck you?
- How rude.
(laughter)
- You are attracted to them
because they look female,
then I don't understand why you
would consider yourself gay.
- How long do you think that you pass?
- Ehh (laughs).
- I see beauty in all
aspects if you are passing
or not passing.
- When did you decide to be trans?
- No, that's not how it works, kids.
None of this is a choice.
It's a choice whether you're
gonna act on it or not.
I thought am I gonna be happy for myself
or miserable for everyone else?
What happens if/when you change your mind?
(laughs)
- Ooh, when are we gonna de-transition?
- I'll have to get my titties removed.
- How do I ask someone their
preferred pronouns politely
if I'm unclear?
That's a good question.
- Like a human being.
You ask them a direct, clear question.
- What if they seem offended?
'cause if I was at
Starbucks and they said,
"What's your preferred pronoun?"
I'd be like, bitch, can I get my latte?
- What's the worse thing a cis
person has ever said to you?
- God doesn't make mistakes.
They're right, I live
a purpose-driven life.
- During my military
experience, we're clearly like
I look masculine, my military
documentation says I'm
a masculine person, but the
records for the military
didn't say that I was
masculine, so the military law
says that they can still
call me female even though
you know you have a medical
team and you have all--
- And you fought for this country.
- If you could tell cis people
one thing, what would it be?
(exhales loudly)
- The murder rate of trans
women, especially trans women
of color, is so high.
- You don't have to understand
us, you don't have to
understand every single gender
identity or trans experience
in the world, but you can respect us.
- You need to stop
projecting onto other people
what you think is normal
because it's not normal,
it's common.
- We just need your support.
- And your understanding.
- And your love.
- And one million dollars each.
- I need one million and one
because I don't want to spend a
dollar and be like oh my God,
I'm not a millionaire anymore.
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)